DAVI THORBURN: In thinking
about how the course has
to evolve given the availability
of all this new technology,
one thing I've especially
thought about-- worried
about, actually-- is how much
of my own lecture material,
which I now have on video to
make available to them, as
against my live performance, and
whether my live performance is
even necessary at all.
How does it differ from-- and I
still haven't worked that out.
For two semesters now,
I have taught the course
with a combination of live
lectures and video lectures.
And I've asked the students
to tell me in commentaries
whether they saw
much difference,
and whether they preferred
one to the other,
or whether they had
strong feelings.
And so far, the
testimony has been, meh.
They don't seem too interested
in the question, which makes
me a little nervous, actually.
So my feeling is that it's
still an open question.
One thing I definitely
have decided
I will be able to do
with this video material
is using it in other courses.
If I an in advanced
course in film,
and students haven't taken
my earlier film course,
I can send them to this
material and have them use it.
So it's immensely valuable
as a teaching tool.
But how to integrate it
into the existing course
remains a conundrum I
haven't quite figured out.
As I've begun to work
on this, now it's
been some years since
I've started to have
some video lectures available.
I think I realize that
I was naive in imagining
that the transition
would be easy,
that moving into a
video format was simply
a matter of
transferring what I say,
because in fact, the live
environment turns out
to be more central
and more important.
And my feelings as I'm
in the life environment
turn out to be more
essential and more important
than they might otherwise be.
There's something about being
in a live environment that
affects me, and I think
other teachers, maybe not
all teachers, but other
teachers very deeply.
I used to have
the fantasy when I
was in front of a large
audience of students,
maybe as many as 100 or 150,
I had the delusion or illusion
that I was in touch with
every student in the class,
and that every single one of
them was paying attention,
and than when they
didn't, I could feel it,
and that I could see
there was a student who
would stop paying attention.
I would somehow walk in
that direction of the class
or get that student's attention.
Now, I'm sure it was a
fantasy because how could you
be aware of 100 students?
But I had the illusion
that I was aware of them.
I was certainly aware
of many of them.
I was aware of them
as individuals.
I was aware of whethet-- and
I felt I had them wrapped.
And when I felt I was losing
them, I would change pace.
Maybe it has something to do
with a theatrical aspect to me
that really doesn't help much
with being a good teacher.
But maybe it does help
with being a good teacher,
and that maybe good
teachers do have
to have a bit of the ham
in them and like being
in front of audiences.
This is a special
problem for the Western,
because it celebrates American
individualism so powerfully.
The iconic scene of
the Western in which
two men wearing gun square
off against each other,
and the quicker one survives,
that scene of the quick draw,
and of the [? dif ?]
and the dusty street,
can be said to be a kind of
embodiment of these values
in which you have
to rely on yourself.
You can't rely on someone else.
You can't rely on
the government.
You can't rely on the Sheriff.
You can't rely on the police.
You can't rely on
your neighbors.
You have to trust yourself.
And in fact, one
of the ways you can
see the power of these
Western mythologies operating,
as it seems to me
in some sense, one
of the great divides
in the States
today over the question
of guns and gun control
is partly grounded in these
myths of individualism,
that the Western
mythology has been
promulgating since before
the advent of the movies.
And I think part of what
makes my teaching good
is that I'm in a kind of trance
when I'm in front of a class,
in the sense that I am utterly
oblivious to what I look
like, I know for one thing.
I have done teachers
nightmare kinds of things,
like having my shirt unbuttoned
without realizing it, or coming
in with my hair incredibly
askew without knowing about it.
Once I gave a lecture at Yale.
I had young children
at the time.
And I had a child.
My wife was with the
two other children.
I had to take a
child to a doctor.
We took him to the doctor.
But I had to go to
give my lecture.
So I took him into
the lecture hall.
And I sat him down in the
corner of the lecture.
And he was about
seven years old.
And he sat nicely in the
seat for a little while.
I wasn't paying
attention to him.
Then he climbed up.
I was lecturing on a stage.
And he climbed up on the stage.
And he went behind me.
And he sat in a big
chair behind me.
And he made faces.
And the students begin to laugh.
And I couldn't understand
what was going on.
But it taught me a great lesson
in the theatrical reality
of the lecture hall.
So I've come more
fully to understand
that things that are
hard to articulate
or that I at least had not
much thought about, certainly
have not been written about
in pedagogical literature,
about the ambiance
of the live classroom
has some effect on lecturing.
I mean it should have
effect in smaller classrooms
even more fully, I think.
But for lectures, I
think it's important too.
And the transition to purely
video lectures loses that.
How big a loss that is,
or whether that loss can
be compensated for in other
ways is a good question.